[Music]
so an epic demonstration in our nation's
capital
organized in eight weeks
do this Dr King own your power
there's one person who can organize an
event of this scale
what the hell would buy Rustin his
attention-grabbing Antics make him an
easy target who must not mention the
unmentionable oh our new offices I'm
demonstrating up of angelic
troublemakers such as yourselves make
sure
[Applause]
you are in August 28th black black white
young old Rich working class or we'll
descend
on Washington DC
this new generation is restless and
angry the pacifist is opposed to using
violence but must be prepared to receive
it you're irrelevant it's Friday night
I've been called worse
derail the fight for racial Justice in
this country a good 10-15 years on the
day that I was born black
I was also born a homosexual
we're calling for a peaceful March on
Washington
we are committed to the cause of
altering the trajectory of this country
towards Freedom
they are the believing freedom and
justice for all
[Music]
or they do not
thank you